hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today let's talk about
overlord
now just for some background on this I'm
not all that late to the party this time
I did try watching overlord years and
years ago now but I kind of just forgot
about it after the first couple of
episodes but over the years whenever
it's come up in conversation people seem
to have a fairly positive opinion on it
and it has three seasons so I thought
why not let's let's give it another go
so I'm now 7 episodes in and I have to
say I'm I'm not feeling it guys I'll
start off with some stuff that I like
though a great example of which is the
core concept of the series having seen a
billion MMO we Sakai before I'm really
bored of the jump into a new game and
explore from level one formula so I was
quite intrigued by the idea of jumping
into this game at the end of its
lifespan there is an old established
world with a main character who has
access to an incredible array of powers
and there was also this really sombre
feeling of loss in that this world was
going to vanish imminently as a result
of the established nature of the game
there's also an entire cast of
characters available to us right off the
bat so it's a bit like stepping into an
already established world which is nice
in one way because it allows us to
access an extended cast of well designed
individuals without having to sloped
through the traditional adventure story
beats of collecting them one by one over
the course of an entire series however
admittedly there is certainly a reason
why stead tradition exists an overlord
runs into some unique character problems
as a result before we get to that though
I think it's imperative that we start
with our series anchor Momonga who is
yet another real-world inhabitant who
become stuck within a game so I think
one of the main issues that I'm having
with overlord is that I don't quite have
a connection to the protagonist and
after seven episodes that's very
problematic for me because it makes me
feel like I don't have any solid
grounding in what's being presented now
some of this is undoubtedly due to the
fact that the only visual depiction we
have of our protagonists at this stage
is a sage like Demon Lord and or
armor-clad warrior now before I go
deeper into that thought I will say that
I do like this idea in theory
having someone find themselves stuck in
an avatar and just dealing with whatever
madness they've conjured for themselves
is something I much prefer to say those
sword art online idea of everyone
becoming what they look like in real
life it's a nice subversion of a
protagonist because we now find
ourselves having to a moat with an
unconventional design however that is
exactly the problem the character design
itself makes that process very difficult
due to the fact that in his two
established forms neither a capable of
any form of facial movement the skull is
completely static as skull should be I
guess and the
helmut of the warrior facade is even
worse it means that in order to truly
express this character the director and
animators would have needed to work in a
major way to emphasize body language and
sadly unless he's in combat I'm a manga
is a figure who spends most of his time
standing or sitting completely still now
this may not be a problem for some
people but I personally find it
incredibly difficult to truly care for
him as a result which once again is
problematic as he is the driving force
of the series and I think this is such a
shame because deep down I do like that
there are some complex ideas at play in
overlord in particular with Momonga
coming to terms with his new identity
and a loss of humanity as a result of
being locked into this specific
character model I find that thought
endlessly fascinating but so far it
hasn't manifested itself beyond a
passing thought here and there and hey
maybe that's the point the idea that my
manga can say kill someone and feel
entirely neutral about it and just wish
that if this demonic aspect was going to
be toyed with that we get to see more of
that seeping into the character like a
random intense bloodlust that he
struggles to gain control over or
something along those lines and maybe
that happens later run an overlord
there's a lot I haven't seen right now
I'm just pretty desperate to see
something other than what I view as a
very stagnant protagonist
and so it falls to the supporting cast
to really bolster overlord thus far and
well as of right now they are criminally
underused so after the first two
episodes I was pretty keen for this
series this time around because I love
the old collection of characters that
had gathered here some of whom do
present admittedly stereotypical designs
and personalities but others are a nice
breath of fresh air but one of the
problems is that because we've been
thrown into an established existence it
very much feels like I'm eavesdropping
on a group of friends who have known
each other since high school
and what overlord highlights really well
in my opinion is just how necessary it
is to have an outside eye within the
series involved when it comes to meeting
or exploring a new character someone who
is unfamiliar with said character so
they can ask questions react to their
weird quirks and just generally present
the perspective of the audience over
what doesn't really have that because
these characters are already so familiar
to each other and even my manga who
hasn't met the living forms of these
NPCs feels like he's known them for
years and years and years which you know
makes perfect narrative sense but it's
not all that helpful to me as a viewer
because at the moment all I have is a
completely shallow view of everyone in
the great tomb of Nazareth you know I
guess that might be alright to start off
a series with but there is an
expectation on expanding upon those
characters and building them as time
goes on however as of episode
seven I can't really say that that has
happened at all the great shame of
overlord seems to be that at least from
what I've seen we take the time to
introduce a grand location a cast of
amazing looking characters and then we
abandon them for the most part in favor
of exploring the outer world and the
stories of the characters who we meet
out there and yes my manga does always
seem to have an escort from the great
tomb with him but they don't seem to
ever get to do much if anything like
that time when he went to save a village
and took a fully geared up Alberta with
him only to stop her every time she even
showed an inkling of doing something so
the one character we did bring with us
on that occasion served no real
narrative purpose and in addition to not
feeling any grounding with my manga I
also don't feel like I have any solid
grasp of his closest allies and at this
point that's over half the cast and it's
come to the stage where I have such
little connection with these characters
that I'm not in any way inspired to
watch the next episode to be honest at
the moment I think the only character
that I have developed a legitimate
connection with is Gazette he's a simple
man loyal and admirable very easy to get
on board with and part of that comes
from a manga being an outside eye when
they met being willing to explore his
character as well as his probably
surroundings however at the same time
all I really wanted to do was get back
into the great tomb of Nazareth and
explore that and as such I did actually
audibly groan when the next story thread
began and it was going to involve my
long ago going undercover as a low-level
adventurer
I think this leads to another issue I
have though which is the world building
right now it's kind of all over the
place and not particularly effectively
presented in my opinion a lot of this
may be attributed to the inevitable
confusion that happens when you take an
established world like Yggdrasil and
then combine it with something entirely
new but at the same time the audience
have no idea what a Drasil was to begin
with so every time there's a moment
which I'm sure is endlessly fascinating
to my manga when a part of Yggdrasil
appears in this new reality to me it's
just like alright sure I guess I'll take
your word for that
because I have no concept of the world
he's inhabited in-game before the ISA
Kai occurred but at the same time I do
see the necessity to shift things like
that because if the world was exactly
the same as Yggdrasil then my manga
would already know everything and there
would be potentially nothing new to
explore at all making this a very very
boring series it's just that when you
take someone from the real world then
throw them into a game mode and then
throw them into another game world which
takes elements from the previous game it
creates complications that are difficult
to convey effectively in a way that true
captivates me at least and I'm sure that
this probably becomes much clearer as
the series goes on but by episode 7 I'm
really looking for a hook to convince me
to keep investing time into the show
instead what tends to happen when I
begin a new episode is that I have
forgotten most of what happened in the
last episode and the ensuing events have
an uphill battle in making me actually
care maybe I just don't want to see a
powerful demon Lord pretending to be an
adventurer for episodes and episodes on
end because while it's nice to get to
know the select group of human
characters it feels like zooming all the
way in on an atom that makes up a
microscopic part of a gigantic
fascinating world that is out there
ready to explore these are the unique
problems that Overlord faces as a result
of its non-standard premise on the one
hand I should probably be praising how
well it's been handled so far given the
incredibly difficult task that the
series set itself by starting at the
pinnacle of power and knowledge it is
very difficult to go on a journey when
you've already attained everything and
other series that start at the more
level one beginning a much more easily
forgiven in the early days we're not
going crazy with their focus because the
protagonist is usually weak and ignorant
a combination that really favors slow
world building what I'll also say for
overlord is that I do enjoy the comedy
for the most part in fact probably one
of my favorite moments in the series
thus far is that random scene in my
mangas bedroom where Demio caches are
better and just casually asks is that a
lord
inés body-pillow and not only that but
they both just moved on as if this was a
fairly innocuous occurrence moments like
that are fantastic and with Alberto in
particular I also do like the
examination of what happens when you
force someone to love you because that
never works out in media and her
obsession with my manga is
simultaneously hilarious and quite
disturbing if I was to continue the
series my hope would be that this does
get expanded upon though and she doesn't
simply become a one-note I love Lord
ions character everytime she pops up
like maybe at one stage she is driven so
mad by love the chick commits a terrible
action it makes me wanna go oh [ __ ] this
is a serious problem but I'm not sure if
I'm putting too much of an expectation
on overload and here's the thing at the
moment I'm not really sure what overlord
is it appears to have a linear story but
it's progressing slowly and weirdly
giving focus to aspects of the world
that I quite honestly could not care
less about I mean there is a notion of
political intrigue in the background for
the various different factions but at
this stage that hasn't been expanded
upon enough to keep my interest it
definitely has some potential especially
since my manga seems to have a sharp
diplomatic mine
so maybe I just haven't placed enough
trust in overlord to continue it further
to where that becomes a selling factor
but it's difficult I think that Overlord
has had a pretty mess start and without
going into spoilers I'd love to know if
any of you have seen it to think it's
worth the investment to continue one
last thing if this first impressions
wasn't negative enough I also have to
say that I have a huge distaste for the
opening and ending of season 1 although
I will say that I enjoy the opening
infinitely more than the ending at least
it has a catchy chorus the ending though
to my ears is just noise an assortment
of random guitar riffs and extremely
distorted vocals and it doesn't do it
for me but yeah I'm going to put it to
you the comments section to see whether
or not I should continue the series so
please do let me in on your own personal
experiences with overlord and by all
means feel free to change my mind in the
least spoilery way possible but that
pretty much does it for my first
impressions of overlord if you enjoyed
this video and the content this channel
produce in general then please do
consider donating to the new world
review patreon because the support of
all of you amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
plot this channel an incredible amount
and if you'd like to join the fun at any
time then please do head over to my
discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan ray takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on Overlord this has been
the new world review and I'll see you
next time
you